I don't think you're going to have a
problem with that one I think that is
going to lunch
all right buddy
what's yet
[Music]
okay
keep going keep going go go go
[Music]
whoo oh that bird must be here that time
yeah that'll work all right
[Music]
all right test number one take it slowly
I know okay why don't you stop it right
there I'm going to just feel it feels
like it's got a bit more gif to go all
right try a little more
[Music]
already I don't think you're going to
have a prom with that one I think that
is going to watch
all right we've pulled this as tight as
we can we've maxed the car out the car
can't pull this any further so hopefully
this will be enough to get it going but
we're losing so much snow the gravel is
a big problem nope
we'll see what happens
Oh
I just realized this entire thing is
heading towards my crotch if it comes
undone from there it is heading towards
my crotch ready it's exciting the first
a little bit and then just gravel oh
that was so close to working as soon as
it launches it's just like ah it's
amazing and then it hits that gravel
where the snow is just melting so quick
and it hits that gravel and it's just
like the brakes just get put on so not
quite we had more snow this thing would
go flying so this is gonna be this again
you